comment savons-nous qu'ils arrivent mademoiselle
Caldwell était la vedette Brad Pitt
vous jouant un enquêteur qui doit
prendre une décision pour sauver sa famille ou une
bataille une épidémie mondiale La guerre froide Z
tombe en crise nous avons perdu la nuit de la
côte est de l'
Europe une fois  cette épidémie commence
ils sont 87 jours avant la fin de l'
humanité
le personnage de Brad est cet homme de tous les jours
le héros accidentel j'ai besoin de vous pour m'aider d'
accord c'est un c'est un mouvement d'été parfait
c'est tous ces éléments de suspense une
épidémie mondiale et il a évidemment
Brad  Pitt
mère nature est un tueur en série personne
n'est mieux que
toi